Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and since Arrow
and the Flash have continued to cast new comic
book characters I wanted to do a villains
power ranking. This will just be for Arrow
Season 3. I might do a version of this for
the Flash in the next week or two.
The newest villain is Komodo, he’s going
to be played by Matt Ward. You may remember
him from Tron Legacy. He was cast as Simon
Lacroix, but in the comics Lacroix is Komodo,
that’s why we say Matt Ward is playing Komodo.
The same is also true for all the other actors.
Usually when they cast someone, they list
them under their alter ego.
Think of it in terms of Batman, Bruce Wayne
is the fake identity. Batman is who he really
is inside, The Dark Knight. So his name Bruce
Wayne, is his alter ego.
Arrow season 3 will refer to pretty much all
of these villains by their real life personas.
With the exception of Ra’s Al Ghul. He has
no alter ego, unless you want to consider
the Demon’s Head. He’s really the same
person no matter who he’s talking too though,
there’s no secret identity.
This list is going to be least powerful to
most powerful starting with Manhunter.
This is the Mark Shaw Manhunter, Not Martian
Manhunter. The one who’s associated with
the Suicide Squad in the comics. He’s going
to be part of a Diggle Amanda Waller story,
so I’m guessing he’s not a flashback character.
Remember, some of the people they’ve cast
are only going to appear in the Hong Kong
Flashbacks and some will only appear in present
day.
Most people associated with Arrow’s version
of the Suicide Squad are hitmen and mercenaries
who for some reason landed on Amanda Waller’s
shit list.
For those that have read the comics, the most
recent version of Manhunter is Kate Spencer,
which gives me some interesting theories for
Laurel.
Mark Shaw was originally a public defender
who later was trained by a secret society
called the Manhunters. He joined so that he
could serve justice to criminals in a more
effective way. Like Frank Castle becoming
the Punisher. And just like the Punisher,
Shaw eventually went a little nuts and started
going way over the line. Effectively becoming
a villain.
This is a really interesting point, yes you
can be a villain even if you’re not trying
to be evil. Think of Shaw as a hero that wandered
off the path. Which is probably how Arrow
is going to treat him. Usually doing something
like that will put you in an ARGUS jail cell.
He was a part of the older Suicide Squad comics,
but like I said. On the show, he’ll just
be butting heads with Diggle.
In the new 52 comics, the reboot. Mark Shaw
is a US Marshall. Still has questionable morality.
I’m kind of curious to see if Arrow does
that mix and match thing where they give Laurel
some aspects of the Kate Spencer Manhunter
blended with Shaw’s hunter in the old comics.
Like Laurel works at the DAs office, she’s
going to be training to fight this season,
either with Wildcat or Oliver, probably both.
So what if they have an episode where she
tries to dispense her own personal justice.
Kind of combining the original Mark Shaw manhunter
with the Kate Spencer manhunter. Kate Spencer
was a Federal Prosecutor in the comics.
I’m not expecting it, but keep your eyes
peeled for non-black canary Laurel kicking
some butt.
Increasing the threat level a little, next
is Thea Queen. I’m not going to call her
Artemis, but I think the show is pushing her
in that direction. I know a lot of you want
her to be Lady Shiva, but think more of Artemis
in Young Justice. Only as more an antagonist
to Team Arrow.
Willa Holland and Colton Haynes actually posted
this picture from the set. You can see the
new short haircut she’s sporting and she’s
also posted pictures from the gym. The show
is still pairing her with Roy but since she’s
on Team Merlyn this year that technically
makes her a villain.
I know a lot of you might not totally be convinced
Thea could ever be a threat to Roy but remember,
she was a champion Archer and Merlyn has the
wisdom of the League of Assassins to use when
he trains her. Oliver had Slade, so I wouldn’t
call one better than the other. But right
now I think
Merlyn is a better teacher than Oliver is.
Part of the fun this season will be watching
Oliver train Roy more and watching Merlyn
train Thea.
Then it will really get fun when Thea starts
kicking Roy’s butt.
Climbing the ladder a little further is Deadshot,
Michael Rowe is guest starring in the Suicide
Squad related episodes. I’m expecting to
see him more than once. There’s going to
at least be one special Suicide Squad episode.
But they get cameos in other episodes. Expect
him to get a really cool story.
Speaking of which, I didn’t put her on the
list but Harley Quinn is supposed to have
a real cameo this season. Like an actual one
that makes it to air. When Cassidy Alexa did
her last season, they had the super short
teaser that got cut out of the Suicide Squad
episode. Then she had another cameo in the
finale that also got cut out at the last minute.
Stephen Amell was pretty vocal about wanting
to see her on the show a couple of months
ago. They probably won’t make any special
annoucements till we get closer. But be prepared
for Harley Quinn.
Just above Deadshot I’m putting Komodo.
He was a huge Green Arrow Villain in the new
52 comics. He was connected to Oliver’s
father and even worked inside Queen Industries.
I don’t know how the show is going to change
him from the comics, but he could potentially
show up in the flashbacks and in present day.
In present day he’ll be connected to Count
Vertigo. There was a comic book plot where
he kidnapped Shado’s daughter and helped
Vertigo so he might end up kidnapping or trying
to kidnap Felicity or Laurel.
Since Laurel’s going to be training if she
does end up fighting Komodo it would be a
pretty cool takedown for her. They’d have
to de-power him a little from his comic book
version. He’s supposed to be Oliver’s
equal and I don’t see Laurel becoming as
good a fighter as Oliver right away.
Next step up we’re getting into supervillain
territory. There’s Talia Al Ghul. She is
coming back as part of the Ra’s Al Ghul,
League of Assassins episodes. Or the episodes
that feature the League.
Black Canary is only back for three episodes,
so I’m expecting Talia to show up sometime
during those.
In terms of fighting ability she’s right
under Oliver. She was able to fight him to
a stand still last season in hand to hand
combat and with a bow. But Oliver is still
stronger just from sheer size.
Some of these upper level characters are better
than each other under certain conditions,
like Talia is more vicious than Oliver or
Merlyn for instance, but both of them are
stronger. A lot of times it just depends on
the conditions of the fight and whether or
not one of them is confounded.
But moving up to my top 3. Amanda Waller.
Yes, I am considering her a villain. She’s
neutral really, but the way Arrow uses her
is mostly as an antagonist. She only helps
Team Arrow when she’s forced to or when
it suits her. If you’re even a little bit
evil, you’re a villain. Villains can still
do good things and continue to be villains.
Just like Merlyn.
I think Waller will be way more evil in the
Hong Kong flashbacks. She’s clearly keeping
Oliver there against his wishes forcing him
to help her.
I know everyone is wondering how he ended
back on the island in the pilot, if that supposedly
came after Hong Kong. It’s probably because
he and Waller had a falling out. I’m hoping
that the flashbacks this season explain why.
Up to number 2 now, Malcolm Merlyn. Who is
nothing like John Barrowman in real life.
Stephen Amell said that the biggest prankster
on set is John Barrowman. Like the kind of
person who will jump from around the corner
with jazz hands to scare you.
I love the thought that Malcolm Merlyn is
a consummate prankster. Like the Tom Hiddleston
Loki of the series. Meaning that even if he
does evil things, he’s really true neutral.
As in he can either swing chaotic neutral
or lawful neutral depending on the situation.
I’m wondering if he’s going to try and
play Team Arrow against Ra’s Al Ghul. Like
use them as a distraction. Or better yet.
Use Team Arrow as a Human Shield.
It’s also totally possible that Merlyn and
Oliver could team up while still being enemies.
Like a temporary truce to fight off Ra’s
Al Ghul.
Stephen Amell said that Oliver and Merlyn
will always have unfinished business, mostly
referring to Tommy and the Earth Shaker. But
Ra’s Al Ghul is the one thing that could
put that fight on hold.
Let me know if you want to one, see Oliver
and Merlyn go at it and two, do you want to
see them team up against Ra’s Al Ghul?
Which of course leads me to the most powerful
villain this season, The Demon’s Head.
The big thing with him this season is what
is compelling enough for him to leave Nanda
Parbat and come to Starling? Usually what
you see is all the villains stories tie together
by the end. So Ra’s Al Ghul will be in Starling
because of something Black Canary does, something
Merlyn does and something Vertigo does.
That doesn’t include any interaction between
Ray Palmer’s story or any of the other heroes
coming on the show. I’ll try to address
that when I do a Hero Power Ranking, be sure
to subscribe to get that video. I’ll post
it next week.
Quick update on Friday Saturday videos. Legend
of Korra season finale will be streaming on
Nickelodeon tomorrow for free. Be sure to
watch it. I’ll post my video afterwards.
And Doctor Who Series 8 Episode 1 on Saturday.
So lots of big stuff happening this weekend.
If you want to follow me for updates I’m
awesomemergency on twitter and emergency awesome
on facebook.
Right now click here for a Justice League
Dark explainer video. And click here for my
big Marvel Avengers 2 Phase 3 Q&A.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!